The G-20 summit ended with a display of unity on the world economy...
...and the show of determination on Iran.
It is time for Iran to act immediately to restore the confidence of the international community...
...by fulfilling its international obligations.
U.S. President Barack Obama called on Iran to come clean about its nuclear plans,...
...following news that it is building a previously undisclosed uranium enrichment facility.
He said Tehran will be held accountable.
This site deepens a growing concern that Iran is refusing to live up to those international responsibilities,...
...including, specifically, revealing all nuclear related activities.
President Obama said US, French, and British intelligence agencies discovered the site about 160 kilometers from Tehran.
The UN's atomic watchdog, the IAEA, is investigating.
British Prime Minister Gordon Brown was blunt.
Confronted by the serial deception of many years,...
...the international community has no choice today but to draw a line in the sand.
French President Nicolas Sarkozy set a deadline.
If by December there is not an in-depth change by the Iranian leaders,...
...sanctions will have to be taken.
Russia approved the message.
But there was disdain from Iran's President Mahmoud Ahmadinejad.
At a news conference in New York,...
...he said Iran followed rules set down in the Nuclear Non-Proliferation Treaty and by the IAEA.
We are operating within the NPT framework and within the framework of the IAEA.
And that is how we will advance our operations.